My name is Neil Shubin.
I'm from the University of
Chicago where I'm a professor
in the faculty of the anatomy
department there.
I also hold an appointment at
the Field Museum of Natural
History, also in Chicago.
So you have to understand
the setting.
The setting of the day we found
it was, this was our
last expedition to the
Canadian Arctic.
We were running out of
money, and I'm not
saying this for drama.
It's really expensive
to work there.
We had worked there for a number
of years already with
very little success.
We had not much to show
for ourselves.
We decided to sort of spend
the lot and have one last
season working at that layer.
So Steve's cracking rocks.
Steve is up about seven feet
from me and he says, hey Neil,
what's this?
And I remember looking at the
thing and saying, OK, we have
a flat-headed fish.
I looked at Ted and Farish who
were the co-leaders of the
expedition.
We were like, oh, my god.
I mean, there were two feelings,
one was just
incredible joy, but the other
was incredible relief.
This was our last
chance at this.
And as soon as I saw what this
object was, I knew we had
found what we had spent six
years and I'd spent 20 years
before looking for.
Well, since I was a graduate
student, I was interested in
one of the great evolutionary
events in earth history, which
is the transition from life
in water to life on land.
And you think about that.
It's a remarkable transition,
because so much in the animals
have to change.
So I got interested early on in
this transition and my goal
was to find new evidence to tell
us about how it happened.
So what I did starting in the
early '90s was to try to find
rocks in the world that had the
right properties to hold
the fossils that would tell us
about this transition, from a
fish that has like a conical
head and fins to a land-living
animal of the time, in the
Devonian, which has a flat
head with limbs.
So we looked around the world
and it eventually became clear
through a moment of serendipity
that one of the
best places and most unexplored
places to look for
such a fossil was in the
Canadian Arctic.
We discovered it from a
geological textbook, not the
scientific literature.
It was completely accidental.
But it turns out these were the
perfect rocks of the right
age and exposed to the surface
to produce such an
intermediate.
And what it looks like is you
have a flat head with eyes on
top, and then you essentially
have the body of what looks
like a fish, a stubby fish,
because it has scales and
stubby fins.
Now, what's great about
Tiktaalik it's a great melange
of characteristics of fish
and land-living creature.
The shape of the head, the
proportions of the head, the
bones, and so forth are very
much like a land-living animal
and then other parts
are fish-like.
What's remarkable about the fin
is when you take out the
fin webbing, it has bones that
correspond to the upper arm, a
humerus, forearm, a radius ulna,
and even portions of the
risk, the so-called proximal
carpel, so a real remarkable
transitional creature.
It had both lungs and gills.
And what's exceptional about
this is just how ordinary it
is in the sense that it's
exactly the intermediate that
you would likely predict.
So what this does, is it tells
us a lot about the shift from
water to land along with the
other creatures that's up
there, hundreds of other fossils
that colleagues around
the world have found.
It tells us a lot
about how this
great transition happened.
When Tiktaalik was announced in
the pages of Nature, we had
two articles which was nice
because it gives us a chance
to do a lot of basic description
of the creature.
Well, it hit a lot of news
headlines in April of 2006
when it came out.
So much so I was dropping my
son of at school the day it
was announced, and his teacher
said, hey, bring in the fish.
So I brought the cast
of fossil, which we
made at that point.
I remember showing if the kids,
and I said, hey, guys,
what do you think it is?
One kid said, oh, it looks
like a crocodile.
And you can see why he said it's
like a crocodile because
it has flat eyes on top
and you can even see
teeth on the side.
Another kid corrected him and
said, no, no, it's a fish.
It's got scales, and
it has fins.
And I said, hey, you're both
right, because they got the
concept right immediately.
And so you know, if only adults
in Louisiana would get
what kids got really quickly
in preschool.
What inspires me is this
transition from life in water
to life on land is not just
some esoteric twig on the
evolutionary tree.
It's very important for us.
It's very important because this
event is part of our own
evolutionary history when our
common ancestor was a fish.
So that this proto wrist we
see for the first time in
Tiktaalik and its evolution
cousins, it's something that
became our own wrists.
This neck that we see for the
first time in Tiktaalik and
its evolutionary cousins is
something that was to become
our own necks.
Inside our organs, inside our
genes, inside our cells carry
artefacts of the history of
life, carry events like this
of which is one of countless
events in the last three
billion years.
The basis for the name, we had
a naming project with the
Inuit elders.
And we have all the
pieces together.
It takes the right geological
conditions.
conditions to find it, and
then it takes almost the right
geological conditions--